Das ist wirklich ziemlich verrückt ist scheint tatsächlich so dass es ihm bald eine art
internet das boot wide web gibt demnach hätten die pflanzen schon millionen jahre vor uns die kommunikation über datenleitungen
Erfunden immer mehr forschungsteams sind mittlerweile von der theorie des sogenannten wood wide web überzeugt das internet
Des waldes ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen facts wie schnell ist das world, wide web
Und wir werden die kosten abgerechnet ja so wegfalls scheint es wirklich
zu geben das alles und viel mehr jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen oder ein ende er vater wieder zur whatsapp kommt
Unzählige informationen gehen tag für tag stunde für stunde ja sekunde für sekunde durchs world wide web
Alles was man davon wirklich sie sind ein paar kabel server und der router in der wohnung
Im wald liegt das netz unter dem laub versteckt und mit seiner hilfe kommunizieren
bäume dazu der zellbiologe frantisek baluska von der universität bonn
Bäume haben ihre eigenen probleme ihre eigenen fähigkeiten mit problemen umzugehen und sie kommunizieren auch miteinander
und lösen die probleme miteinander
und diese kommunikation der pflanzen ist tatsächlich erst seit einigen jahren als
Seriöse wissenschaftliche fragestellung anerkannt doch mitarbeiter steht fest bäume
Kommunizieren nicht nur über duft botschaften sondern auch über pilze konkret handelt es sich um sogenannte mykorrhiza
Weiße pilzfäden die tatsächlich mit dem fun wurzelsystem der bäume kontakt aufnehmen und botschaften an andere
Pflanzen sträucher und bäume übermitteln genau wie beim world wide web werden durch das world wide web also
unzählige nachrichten von baum zu baum gefunkt die jeweils in einem netzwerk zusammen gebunden sind experimente zeigen dass sowohl wasser
kohlenstoff und nährstoffe zwischen den bäumen transportiert wird und zwar ganz individuell abgestimmt auf die verschiedenen bedürfnisse
droht den nachbar bäumen beispielsweise auch der befall durch insekten
kommuniziert dass die kastanie an ihren nachbarn weiter alles wird einigen studien zufolge tatsächlich über sogenannte
Mutter bäume gemanagt ähnlich wie beim film avatar, im übertragenen sinne sind pilze also die
glasfaserverbindung des waldes forschungsteams nennen genau diese verbindung mit web und das gesamte ausmaß das kann, man
sich kaum vorstellen denn die pilze dem wir
Im wald sehen das sind nur die früchte die eigentlichen pilze findet man unterirdisch und dort sind sie
riesengroß teilweise
quadratkilometern das größte lebewesen der welt ist ein pilz es ist ein dunkle hallimasch größe
1200 fußballfelder gewicht
600 tonnen zum verständnis
Wenn ein pilzsammler also einen steinpilz findet und meint einen pilz gefunden haben ist das in etwa so als wenn man einen
Einzigen ab befindet und sagt hey ich hab einen apfelbaum gefunden der pilz selbst ist also ein riesiges geflecht die
pilze sind nur die früchte oder blüten wie bei blumen die dann die sporen die samen
Verbreiten und wir kennen das als internet user nur allzu gut um das internet nutzen zu können müssen wir zahlen
Und so geht es auch den bäumen die wirklich
Hohe kosten haben konkret stellen die pilze also die möglichkeit der kommunikation heer also das internet
Dafür bekommen sie nahrung von. Den bäumen. Im klartext zuckerlösung und das nicht. Zu knapp bis zu einem drittel der gesamten
Photosynthese produktion müssen die bäume an die pilze
Zahlen eine art symbiose also die pilze können sich nicht selbst ernähren sie sind auf das angewiesen was ihnen andere lebewesen zur verfügung stehen
Stellen die bäume können erst durch die hilfe der pilze
kommunizieren die wichtigste frage neben den kosten ist natürlich die geschwindigkeit und die ist den ball ziemlich gering
forschungsteams schätzen die nachrichtenübertragung auf etwa einen zentimeter pro sekunde
Und das ist für die bäume
Im wald mehr als ausreichend die wissenschaft tut sich mit diesem thema, also dem
Verhalten tatsächlich noch etwas schwer es ist also noch nicht wirkliche lehrmeinungen es gibt noch
Unsicherheiten also ist die these noch er im stadium der hypothese aber
mittlerweile gibt es publikationen die eine kommunikation zwischen solchen baum pilz netzwerken
nachgewiesen haben wenn man davon ausgeht dass pflanzen kommunizieren sind viele fragen offen verfügung pflanzen über ein sozialverhalten
Denn kommunikation ist schließt sich eine soziale handlung sind bäume
sozialwesen dazu der biologe baluska ich für meinen teil davon aus dass pflanzen lebewesen sind wenn sie aber
lebewesen sind müssen sie auch ein
sozialverhalten haben als beispiel nennt der forscher in einem interview junge bäume die in einem ganz dichten wald wachsen normalerweise
Müssten sie absterben da sie kaum licht bekommen doch wenn sie mit den großen bäumen drumherum verwandt sind
bekommen sie zucker über das pils netzwerk und wachsen weiter baluska geht sogar noch weiter
er ist sich sicher dass bäume auch ein gedächtnis haben denn offensichtlich
Nehmen sie die daten ihrer umwelt nicht nur war sondern speichern sie und stellen sich damit auf veränderungen ein
Mehr, als 20 parameter die sich ständig verändern nehmen bäume demnach aus der umwelt wahr und
auf dieser grundlage treffen sie dann entscheidungen beispielsweise
Entscheidet sich eine wurzel dann ob sie nach links rechts nach oben oder nach unten wächst all diese erkenntnisse die es weiter
zu erforschen gilt können uns nur viele hinweise bezüglich unserem umgang mit pflanzen geben wie beispielsweise in der land und forstwirtschaft beispielsweise
folgt daraus den schluss dass
Ältere erwachsene bäume wichtig für das wachstum der jüngeren sind also würde es vorteile bringen wenn wir in der forstwirtschaft die sogenannten
mutter bäume bestehen lassen außerdem sollten wir unter rücksichtnahme auf unterirdische netzwerke den vorgang des pflügens
Bewusster einsetzen ja und wenn ihr als erstes neues zu diesem thema
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp
Dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen von mir
vom neuesten video eben vorab garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von krieg zum mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder andere vorschläge machen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach ihr drauf kriegen und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf kriegen pflanzen mit superkräften das spannendes thema ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran